I love what you're somewhere and they're
like just so you know
These Wings Are like 22 and I'm like
yeah that's fine and then like
oh yeah
[Music]
do you guys know about NASA's new
Artemis space shuttle mission nope
what'd you say like that thanks
everybody for watching I thought NASA
was like defunded or some [ __ ] it has
been but they actually had funding the
past couple years like five years ago
and they were able to scrap together
enough to afford this new art Artemis
Mission which is the the basically the
first steps to get us back to the Moon
[Music]
um for whatever the [ __ ] reason yeah why
do we want to go back we want to go back
to the moon so we can um build there so
that when we launch missions to Mars we
can Refuel on them oh so that's our
Chevron
it's our Barstow yeah exactly that's our
bar stuff
Moon looks like Barstow we're gonna open
up Peggy sues on [ __ ] and put a
Raising Cane's there man get some alien
jerky up there I'm Donia and and there's
enough they think there's there's enough
oil on the Moon from dead dinosaurs that
we could refill the rocket
wait what what happened wait what
mainly stegosauruses oh
for some reason stegosauruses were on
the mountains
gasosaurus no we're going to use water
we're gonna use water okay whatever and
well a mixture of different things on
the moon so water's on the moon water's
on the moon why not when an electrical
an electric shuttle
I don't think it'll be I don't think you
can plug it in I mean here's my question
for you I guess how long how how far can
you take an electric vehicle on the
planet Earth
oh it depends which one
I think the most is only like 300 miles
400 miles 300 yeah
the [ __ ] you're gonna go to Mars with
this [ __ ] I think you can [ __ ] plug
it in and you have an extension cord
coming to Earth
sounds stupid well hey if you could put
a USB cable in someone's penis I really
feel like you can put an electrical cord
on them you can put it in someone's
penis but then there's all kinds of
problems they charge from your body
though I I heard that it didn't it does
not charge me oh it does unfortunately
charges from a potato though you could
do that from a potato but that's it and
that has nothing to do with
stegosauruses on the moon yeah but like
if the rocket was electrical imagine
like how dope it would be that there's
not there's no sound on the rocket line
that would be really nice for the people
who live in Florida yeah or if the whole
[ __ ] is covered in solar panels
maybe yeah those little things just
charging by itself and you get close to
the Sun yeah it wouldn't be sound in
space anyway though right well but so
it's really expensive it takes like
[ __ ] forever Roi yeah you gotta clean
them too someone paid attention in
science class I heard that space it
smells like burnt rubber it smells like
burnt steak apparently that's bad
according to Mark Kelly who was up there
forever yeah he says it's supposed to be
burnt steak what does Buzz Aldrin say
about the smell of space Alden said
space is fake yeah yeah he's like what
[ __ ] space he's like we didn't go
smells like a studio
so what is this Artemis uh so so the
Artemis mission is about getting us back
to the Moon
um but unfortunately there has been a
delay and really the guy who is in
charge of moving this 130 foot long 114
foot wide many many many colossal tons
space vehicle is pissed about it because
every time they delay anything he has to
move it all the way out to tarmac and he
has to move it back
he's like are you [ __ ] kidding me but
how many guys are they getting to move
it back well he's in charge of it right
so there's there's a whole operation to
move it using a lot of different
Vehicles like operation demo drop but
over and over and there's one NASA
driver that's trying to [ __ ] get it
going
and they're like push it faster exactly
and the Cadillac converter keeps getting
stolen wait is it because like he's
using day laborers and then the good
ones always keep leaving that's what it
is yeah they keep getting hired
elsewhere yeah do you know if the uh the
super Asian Johnny Kim is part of this
whole mission it says he's not really
where's he
is here I think yeah he started an
Instagram so I followed him he's always
doing like the craziest [ __ ] what's the
next thing he's gonna so recently he's
uh been flying like [ __ ] in the ozone
or some [ __ ] like where it's like so you
have regular fighter jets but I guess
like when you master that that's too
[ __ ] for you then you start flying
where you're like like not in outer
space but you're like still you're above
I guess like Top Gun too they call it
they call it so it's called not yet
space okay so not yet space and this
[ __ ] is so hardcore he had this
[ __ ] mask on right he took it off no
no then he's uh I guess like when you
have this mask it's like a low oxygen
environment he was like oh spaghetti
through spaghetti meatballs throw a
straw is not that bad because I guess
like when you're up there he has like
space MREs or some [ __ ] because you're
up there for so long so he has like in
his mask there's a [ __ ] tube that
comes out and there's a bag of [ __ ]
spaghetti and meatballs that he has to
like how do you eat that through a pipe
like a boba straw I don't know but I
guess he has the meatball gets stuck
dude yeah he stopped pee and [ __ ] on
himself or I don't know sometimes in a
really badass it kind of sucks hey like
he's too good nobody else you're just
doing some the craziest [ __ ] that no one
else wants but I bet like till this day
that's the reason why he's still
accomplishing [ __ ] is because he never
got his full acceptance from his parents
and his mom like every achievement that
he has she's like well are you in space
yet yeah and he's like I'll [ __ ] I'll be
in space he goes did you break a record
in space though and he goes oh [ __ ] it
I'll break I'll break up did you argue a
legal case in space though yeah and then
so she keeps like pushing it and then
he's gotta [ __ ] meet that new bar
dude ate spaghetti through a straw
before yeah cause did you [ __ ] on
yourself yeah I like the idea that he's
actually up in space and she's like it
doesn't matter because you didn't pass
the bar you're not a lawyer yeah that's
but that's how Koreans are brought up so
like when people go like how you doing
like I'm Korean it could always be
better that's how we brought up it can
always be better like my I got all A's
well you need to get all eight pluses
you know so what's above an eight plus
though if I get all a pluses what's in
that clearly because you're white you
don't know you've never been there a
plus plus
but that's a real thing that's 110 not
for you know not for not I have no hope
for that I know that that's why I'm a
[ __ ] boy so I'm dressed like yeah but
it's popular yeah but it's always like
that uh you know what's funny is you
guys know LegalZoom of course what are
the part one of the partners is Founders
is Korean so obviously they have he has
parents and then so the the friends of
his of his parents there's no bragging
what can you possibly say their their
son is like I don't know probably like a
billionaire or something close what can
you say oh my son's a doctor and he just
he made a million dollars this year okay
cool I'm going to move a million dollars
so like they said that Circle there's no
Bragging because of that one so there's
no Bragging Allowed no it's not that
it's allowed it's like there's no point
yeah yeah because you can't you can't do
it you can't modify it even on the
inside of these circles because all the
parents had to live for is just to brag
about their kids oh yeah yeah like
especially if they're rich parents
that's all they [ __ ] happen because
they have no accomplishments of their
own well they're they're they did they
did well but but everyone did well in
their neighborhood so now it's like what
are what are your kids doing did you do
well at raising your kids yeah so now
it's all about that and like they do
like almost like little chess Wars with
each other about well my kids doing this
all my kids doing this oh yeah well my
kids got this and my kid oh Checkmate
that it's like [ __ ] crazy you'd be
like but did you see my [ __ ] tree
it's the biggest one on the Block you
son of a [ __ ] yeah see that's what I
would brag about I got the biggest
goddamn mango tree on the whole street
that to me is amazing like if you can if
you can have a fruit tree that
successfully grows fruit year in year
out do you guys want to infiltrate these
family groups so you can just sit there
and fight with them sometimes no but I
would love to be like the the parent
group the friend group of Johnny's
parents why okay because like you can
hear
with other parents like oh yeah my son
just got his laundry oh the his parents
just dunk on everybody yeah but then
Johnny's like orbiting the Earth right
now they're like you know
Johnny's parents are like
and I would just sit there and laugh
like really you're such a space loser
he failed the Navy Seals and he failed
being a doctor yeah no space because of
that yeah there's no nobody around I bet
the next thing is like but you're not a
Supreme Court Judge though you're a
lawyer but not a [ __ ] Supreme yeah
but is there a wife in space are you
gonna get are you gonna have kids out
there it's always something exactly if
they'll find they'll find an Achilles
heel they'll find something they're
really good at that yeah because people
are like watch it why do you like young
girls except aside from the obvious
reasons when you take a young girl out
for steak and lobster she's like oh my
god I've never had anything like this
but you take a girl in her 40 steak and
lobster like she's like okay I've been
here before like you take her to a fancy
restaurant they know her name because
she's been there every week oh yeah I
come here all the time it's like like
what's next you have to take them to
space like you know oh I've already been
here too they're like the manager of
that restaurant yeah it's like you know
there's no impressing and you know for
men as shallow and as like weak and uh
weak-minded as we are like we wanna we
wanna impress a girl yeah and if we
can't impress her because she's only
been there like 20 times it's like yeah
that's why I need them young enough or
they they think Disneyland's amazing
take him to DZ Discovery Zone like
they're hype they're super hype yeah
they get [ __ ] hyped on it yeah right
like you go like you know like if you
take her to Applebee's and she's like oh
my God like I've only had like you know
tater tots at Applebee's but you're
gonna get steak and lobster oh you must
really like she's like we get to the two
for 40 deal yeah
you're like the first guy that didn't
take me to wiener schnitzel and the
waiter's like sir we're gonna need you
to do a credit report because we're not
sure that you'll be able to cover all
this
put his hands like this I'm so sorry you
realize that this is um 82 right
and you also got dessert too so I'm not
even gonna I love it when you're I love
when you're somewhere and they're like
just so you know
These Wings Are like 22 and I'm like
yeah that's fine and they're like
oh yeah
you wanted the extra Ranch so that's
another dollar you know that right yeah
you're not gonna kill me when you come
might come back with it that's Chipotle
dude you know before I add these
avocados they're extra charged yeah that
also means they've had some nightmare
customer that they're so they got the
PTSD and they want to like be preemptive
about it and they're like wow that's a
dollar fifty do you guys do you guys
remember a guppy tea house yeah yeah
yeah yeah so is it still a route no it's
it's gone now there's a Riverside too
right UCR oh they're all gone yeah yeah
in one night they just like all
disappeared yeah we don't want to be
Guppies we're goldfish now they used to
have these uh chicken wings that uh I
guess they would take a long time so
people would always complain so to
remedy that next to the price they would
write 15 minutes
so that way you knew that if your orders
would take 15 minutes it's actually 45
minutes but 15 minutes
it really took 15 minutes but what we
would do is like because if you order
the wings even if it says that you go oh
can I just get the wings the waiter
would always go oh you know that's going
to take 15 minutes right and they you
just go yeah I know that so after a
while to save time we would just go uh
I'll take the 15 minute wings and then
there it would always catch them off
guard they would go oh the 15 minute
wigs will take 15 okay
okay that's how I am with uh McDonald's
because I know my order like crazy and I
know what they're gonna ask yeah and
then I can tell they're on autopilot
because I'll go whatever whatever meal
and I always go uh I'll take that large
with Coke extra ice and then if they're
on autopilot okay I got it says so what
did you want to drink okay okay
I'm just sitting there like yes because
I know all the questions catching
someone's autopilot is pretty [ __ ]
funny man dude I just give up at this
point with fast food and getting my
drink because I go there just to get
like a Diet Coke with no ice yeah I
don't get food I'm getting I'm just like
can I get a Diet Coke noise and then
they always give me ice and I just I
just don't care anymore
I just need to drink I just need to
drink diet coke with ice and that's what
God is telling me that's what the raw
the Sun God wants me to do that's what
Zeus wants me to do that's what everyone
wants me to do I broke it now I give up
on it dude it's over
ice it just watered it down and it
[ __ ] it gets not the deal